ERIC SCHMIDT: Good
afternoon, or if you watch us
online, whatever time it
may be there in the future.
My name's Eric Schmidt.
I'm a product manager here at
Google on the Cloud Platform
team.
This is the Google Talks
or Talks at Google series.
Today it's a pleasure
to welcome the VP
from Sub-Pop records, Ms. Megan
Jasper-- Mrs. Megan Jasper,
or is it Miss?
MEGAN JASPER: It's so weird.
I never use any of those.
I guess it's Ms. or Mrs. You
can call me anything you want.
I've probably been called
way worse than anything
you can dream of.
ERIC SCHMIDT: Great.
Well, thanks for joining us.
In full disclosure, you
and I talked about this.
So I also DJ at KXP
90.3 down the street.
So whenever I was asked to
do this, I was like, wow,
this is amazing.
I get to talk to you and get
to play in the music space
while we nerd out at Google.
So thank you for
being here today.
MEGAN JASPER: Thank
you for having me.
I truly appreciate it.
ERIC SCHMIDT: Sure.
So I think most of
the folks in the room,
maybe, but
potentially not online
may not understand
really what Sub-Pop is.
Yes, it's a record label.
And it's here in Seattle,
but what is Sub-Pop Records?
MEGAN JASPER: Sub-Pop
records is a record label
based in Seattle.
And we have been around for
officially almost 28 years.
But we are an
independent label, which
is also kind of a funny
term to throw around,
because we're 49% percent
owned by Warner Music.
But what we do is we focus
on developing artists.
And we work with bands that
sometimes a small handful
of people know
about, and we hope
that we are able to develop
their careers to a point
where they can really make
a living as an artist.
That's always our goal,
so long as that's what
the artist's goal is as well.
But that's what we do.
We've worked with
parents who have become
as popular as Nirvana, or
Flight of the Conchords,
some comedians like David Cross,
the Shins, the Postal Service.
And we work with
a lot of artists
that still very few
people know about
but that are important
enough in our eyes
that we can't imagine
not trying to expose
their art to the world.
ERIC SCHMIDT: One of
the things I personally
love about Sub-Pop is that
especially from a communication
perspective, you're always
very consistent about what you
believe in and what
you don't believe
in to the extent on the site
there's no definitive mission
statement about, like,
this is Sub-Pop's mission.
But the one thing they do say
is that at the end of the day,
the label's about
serving artists.
And as most
consumers-- and there
are some producers
of music here--
can you shed some light
on what specifically
serving artists means?
Like, what happens
on a daily basis?
What you do to nurture
them and help them?
MEGAN JASPER: And I have to
say I love that you brought up
the fact that we don't have
a mission, because that's
something that we've talked
about for so many years.
Because we are a
mission-driven organization,
but a mission-driven
one without a mission,
or a declared mission.
And there are times when I say
to Jonathan, who owns Sub-Pop,
I think we need a
mission statement.
And he'll be like, yeah.
It would probably go something
like, meow, meow, meow, meow
with developing artists and
community and while having fun,
and maybe a little
extra meow, meow, meow.
And then we don't have a
declared mission statement.
Because we're just, like,
yeah, that sounds good.
Go back to work.
So we say, when we
talk in meetings,
we say, our goal is to serve
the artists with whom we work.
And what that means is the
development of those careers.
And what that means
in daily practice
is, first off, really getting
to know those artists, which--
it's funny.
I think the first place a lot
of people's minds would go
is what it means marketing-wise
what it means sales-wise.
And although those are
very important things,
I think the most important
thing is knowing the people
that you're working with.
Because you can't serve
them if you don't know
who they are-- if you don't
know who they are as people
and as artists.
So for us, what that means
is, what are your goals?
How do you want to
present yourself?
How do you want to make your art
and then express it afterwards?
Do you want to go on tours?
Does that stress
you out too much?
Do you have family and you
need to prioritize your kids?
How is that going to work?
Because if we
understand those things
and what makes those
people come to life
or what makes them
shut down, then we
can understand what
situations to put them
or to spare them from
being thrown into.
And so that's a huge
part of it, is just
knowing who they
are, and from there,
making sure they're able to
make a record that they feel
proud of, making sure
that they have a record
that they feel like they
could stand behind and go
out and tour on.
And we then do marketing
around all of those things
and then hope that the record
sales or that the streaming
is at a volume that can
bring in money for them,
and ultimately, that
they can have the careers
but they want to have.
ERIC SCHMIDT: It's
interesting, as I was listening
to all those things, it
was not until the very end
that you really start
to talk about money.
And maybe if you
could explain a bit,
we'll talk a little bit about
Hardly Art, the other label
of the label in a bit.
But can you explain
how in today's terms,
how Sub-Pop does make money?
MEGAN JASPER: Yeah.
We make money in a
lot of different ways.
And for an industry
that has been screaming,
the sky is falling,
for so many years now,
we still make the majority of
our money off of record sales.
And what sales-- the word
"sales" now means how many--
still, even though the
number is declining-- how
many CDs doesn't a band sell.
We don't make CDs
for every band.
But if we don't make CDs
for say, Beach House,
we're losing sales.
So how many CDs are selling?
How much vinyl a selling?
It's a lot.
And, what are we able to get
still in downloads and streams?
That's what sales means.
We also are able
to do a lot of-- we
get licensing opportunities
for our artists.
And what that means is we
look into opportunities
with music supervisors
who are placing music
for ads, TV, film-- whenever
opportunities exist out
there that their songs
may be a good match for.
And if the artist is OK
with those opportunities
then we attempt to secure them.
We also do a fair
amount of merch.
We make t-shirts and hoodies
and all sorts of stuff
that you might not need,
but people buy them.
And we're able to give
some of that money
to the artists, which is great.
And we look for international
opportunities as well.
We're doing all
of the same things
that we do in the US in other
countries with partners.
It almost sounds old-fashioned.
ERIC SCHMIDT: No, I
was waiting for you--
I don't know if you've seen
the movie Spaceballs with Mel
Brooks.
He's going, "merchandising,
merchandising."
Do you remember that?
If you could hold this up--
this may be a flashback for you,
but an engineer on the team that
I work with, Bill [INAUDIBLE],
he sent me an email
this morning and said,
I just dug this up
from my basement.
And I asked him when he got it
and he believed it was 1991.
And if you look at the tag--
MEGAN JASPER: It
looks like it's 1991.
ERIC SCHMIDT: If you look at the
tag, it even feels like 1991.
It's heavy, like that's when
our t-shirts were made out
of real ingredients.
And it was black
at the time, right?
So how can you explain the
origin of the word "loser"?
MEGAN JASPER: I sure can.
ERIC SCHMIDT: Because
this is a mystery.
Even on the internet,
with all the information
we have and Google's great
search engine, still it's
kind of confusing as to
why Loser is on that shirt.
MEGAN JASPER: Yeah.
I can also tell you that
this t-shirt was printed
by a guy named Jeff Ross, who
was doing our early shirts back
in the day.
And I know that because
I recognize the tag.
And I'm old, so I
remember this shit.
So Loser was a term that
Sub-Pop started using in 1988.
And here's what I
love about Loser,
is the people who
started Sub-Pop
and worked at Sub-Pop
and not just Sub-Pop,
but the people who were
music geeks and old punk
rockers at that
time, were usually
total misfits in the day.
And that's kind of
where Loser comes from
is that feeling of
just not fitting in.
And then you find a community or
a group of people or something
that you feel like
you belong to.
And then you kind of feel
like a winner, right?
So when Bruce and John were--
Bruce Pavitt and Jonathan
Poneman, who were
Sub-Pop's co-founders,
when they started doing
The Singles Club, which
was a release of limited
seven-inch singles
that would go out to
people, you would say,
yes, I would love
to sign up and I'll
get one limited colored vinyl
single every single month
for one year.
And then you send your $60 in.
Sub-Pop gets money
really quickly,
which was very
helpful at the time.
And you can get these
singles and then
sell them for a ton of
money afterwards, that's
what a lot of people did.
But they used the word
Loser in their campaign.
They said, Hey Loser, come
join our singles club.
And we had a lot of
losers signing up.
And then they were like,
God, this is great.
Let's make Loser t-shirts.
And I remember the first
time I saw a Loser t-shirt.
It was spring 1989.
And Tad was playing at a
really small club in Manhattan.
And I had not yet
moved to Seattle,
but I was just about too.
And he was wearing the white
version of this t-shirt.
And I remember looking at it
and going, God, that's so good.
Because Loser, it resonates.
ERIC SCHMIDT: It
has this dual mode.
Like, inwardly, as
people look at it,
they have some emotional,
maybe, sympathy for you,
like this person is
broadcasting they're a loser.
But as soon as you attack
them, this idea of, I'm
banded with the rest of
losers and there's power.
MEGAN JASPER: Yes, and
it makes you feel proud.
And so there are people who
go to the airport store.
We have a store
at Sea-Tac airport
and we sell the Loser shirt.
And there are folks
who go in there
and they're like, why Loser?
But I mean, hello.
We're fucking losers!
ERIC SCHMIDT: I'm going to get
back to your f'ing loser issue
in a minute.
But I want to--
specifically to yours-- I
want to talk a little
bit about loserdom.
So right now, Sub-Pop is
offering a set of scholarships
for $15,000 to help eligible
high school seniors achieve,
as you call it, their
focused education as a path
to loserdom.
And I read this.
I'm an artist and
I'm also a nerd.
But I felt a little passively
discriminated, like,
is this the only path that I
can choose to get to loserdom
is to basically focus
on music, or are there
other paths, other
elements to this?
MEGAN JASPER: For
that scholarship,
it can be any kind of art.
So it can be visual art.
It can be dance.
We had one person get the
scholarship who made fanzines.
It's more creative endeavors.
ERIC SCHMIDT:
Excellent, excellent.
I feel less
discriminated against.
All right, so whenever I was
prepping for the interview,
I reached out to my friends
at the station-- Cheryl
Waters, Kevin Cole, John
Richards-- and said,
hey, I'm having a
challenge trying
to find interesting things
other than what's coming up
on regular search on Google.
And I said, can
you please help me?
Like, I need dirt.
MEGAN JASPER: I'm so psyched.
ERIC SCHMIDT: Their
unanimous reply--
and I concatenated them,
for anonymity reasons.
We'll see if you can
guess who they are.
And the unanimous reply was,
I hope FCC violations aren't
an issue for you.
She swears like a sailor
with Tourette's and can't
be fazed by anything.
I can't think of a
more fun interview.
She's a riot.
There's nothing you can say
that will shock Megan Jasper.
MEGAN JASPER: I guess
that's John Richards.
ERIC SCHMIDT: Yeah.
It's a combination
of John and Cheryl.
That was it.
They just smiled and they
were like, good luck.
MEGAN JASPER: They've all
heard some really terrible,
nasty stuff fly out of this.
ERIC SCHMIDT: Face to face, they
told me. some, but none of it
was documented.
So for email
purposes, we're good.
So quick, favorite
coffee shop in Seattle?
MEGAN JASPER: C&P
in West Seattle.
ERIC SCHMIDT:
Yeah, that's great.
MEGAN JASPER: Lighthouse
Beans, delicious.
Close second, Real Fine, also
in West Seattle, just opened up.
Their coffee is fucking killer.
ERIC SCHMIDT: And C&P is
family-owned, which is great.
Cam and Pete.
Beer, wine, or both or none?
MEGAN JASPER: I like wine.
ERIC SCHMIDT: Wine.
Red?
MEGAN JASPER: Yes.
I also love a Sauvignon Blanc.
ERIC SCHMIDT: So finally,
why do you hate to cook?
What's up with that?
MEGAN JASPER: It's so stressful.
And I just can't
fucking handle it.
So you guys know, you
work all day, right?
And you're tired and, OK,
so you can go for a walk
or you can cook in a kitchen,
after having been indoors
all day long.
That sounds terrible to me.
Plus, I don't trust-- I
like playing with colors,
but I don't understand how
to translate that to flavors.
And so anything
I'm going to make
is going to be kind of a bummer.
I like baking.
Can't handle cooking.
I'd rather have hemorrhoids.
[LAUGHTER]
I don't want to be stressed
out when I'm at home.
Thankfully, my way better half
and more presentable half,
Brian, he's a really good cook.
ERIC SCHMIDT: So the first
search result in Google is,
quote, "foul-mouthed and
community-minded Sub-Pop
records executive Megan Jasper."
What would your mom
think about this
if she was here and
got to see this,
that that's the
first search result?
MEGAN JASPER: She'd
say, the apple
doesn't fall far from the tree.
ERIC SCHMIDT:
Excellent, excellent.
In the '90s, you were a
member of a band, Dickless.
So you weren't a
founding member,
but you joined as a vocalist.
By the way, if you Google
Dickless Megan Jasper,
it's OK to look at the results.
And the images.
MEGAN JASPER: And, by
the way, "vocalist"
is a very generous word.
ERIC SCHMIDT: I'm just
getting what Wikipedia
and the other thing said.
My question is, if Sub-Pop's
business depended upon it
today, would you sign them?
MEGAN JASPER: Oh, hell no.
No.
I mean, if Kelly Canary
were still in the build,
absolutely yes.
If I was in the band, hells no.
I would be fired, and should be.
ERIC SCHMIDT: You don't
think the serving artist
power of Sub-Pop could save
the band at that point?
MEGAN JASPER: No.
I mean, let's just
say my talents are not
in the spotlight.
Kelly Canary is a
different story, though.
ERIC SCHMIDT: I was listening
to some of the tracks.
And some of it was amazing--
others not so much.
But that's why
there's so much music.
So let's talk about
some other artists
that you did sign to
get an inside view.
First one, Father John Misty.
Is he really as dreamy and
as mysterious in person
as his music leads
you to believe he is?
MEGAN JASPER: That's
a good question.
ERIC SCHMIDT: And by the
way, full disclosure,
I have a man crush on him.
So that's why I picked him.
MEGAN JASPER: As you should.
Did I just goof this thing up?
Sorry.
Can you hear me?
He is one of the most talented
artists we've ever worked with.
And in person, you get
all of the elements
that he shows onstage,
but way less exaggerated.
He is so razor-sharp
smart, it's crazy.
He sweats over every word.
But there's no delay
in him picking a word.
And he is a funny
motherfucker, man.
He is hilarious.
ERIC SCHMIDT: So he's like a
funny Paul Simon with a beard
and not as irritating.
MEGAN JASPER: Yes.
ERIC SCHMIDT: Cool.
All right.
MEGAN JASPER: He
dances less in person
too when you're
just hanging out.
ERIC SCHMIDT: Awesome.
Fleet Foxes-- explosive growth.
I mean, I remember
whenever they had
the station the first
time and then everyone
was addicted to them.
And then things changed.
Forget-- it was the lead singer.
Can't remember, decided
to go back to college.
What's next?
Do you have any
insider information?
Like, are they starting to
circle the castle again?
MEGAN JASPER: Yes.
Robin is writing new material.
I am hoping, as
a fan, that he is
getting ready to perform again.
He took a lot of time off.
He also is-- he is such a
gifted human being in that he's
just-- he's a really
talented musician
and he is a really bright,
interesting, dynamic person who
has the capacity
to do an awful lot.
I hope he starts
playing shows again.
I know he's writing stuff.
ERIC SCHMIDT: Literally, the
hairs on the back of my neck
are standing up knowing
that this is happening.
MEGAN JASPER: I know.
The world needs
more music by him.
ERIC SCHMIDT: Mudhoney,
one of the founding four,
if you will-- we'll talk
about the founding four
at the beginning of
the label-- what's
the key to their longevity?
So I'm good friends
with their sound guy,
and we share stories
here and there.
But they seem to be
on tour all the time.
And they look the same
and they sound the same.
How do they do it?
MEGAN JASPER: Well, fillers.
They get grunge fillers.
Well, they tour a lot,
but they don't tour a ton.
Because Guy is a nurse.
He is an ER nurse at Harborview.
So they have to be really
careful with their schedule.
And they all have kids, except
for Mark, who works at Sub-Pop.
He manages our warehouse.
I think of that even though
they-- we all grow up
and we're all getting older.
But I think they've just
held on to-- I think they
love playing together still.
I think they've held
onto a lot of the beliefs
that they've always had.
And I think they
have fun touring
and just being
around each other.
And they are family, that band.
And they write a great song.
And they perform-- have you
guys seen Mudhoney play ever?
If you have, you know that
that's something so special.
And seeing Mark transform from
actually a very presentable,
normal guy to the thing he
is on stage is unbelievable.
It's unbelievable.
But he is a great front person.
And they're just kind of magic.
ERIC SCHMIDT: I see that the
concept of family and stability
a lot-- Eddie Vedder,
Dave Matthews,
et cetera, as they're bouncing
around the city, family's
very important to them
connect into record labels,
other bands, venues, et cetera.
So that seems like one of those
keys for people out there.
It's like, it's just not about
chasing, chasing, chasing.
You still gotta settle down
and nurture your roots.
So your desk at work-- you can't
see it online, how much drugs
are filled in that desk?
Is it just like we see on vinyl?
Like, you just have
every drug as possible
that's needed to do your job?
MEGAN JASPER: I have
mounds of cocaine.
You just never know when you're
going to just feel sleepy.
And I have just shitloads
of dope and everything
you could imagine,
rolled up bills.
No, my desk compared
to that show
is like the Mickey Mouse Club.
I usually have a cup of coffee.
I am so the boring version
of what that show is.
But I will say that my
desk is way sloppier
than anyone's on that show.
I like it when the
house is clean,
but I apparently don't like
it when my office is clean.
Because I do everything
to screw that up.
And I have piles
of shit everywhere.
But I know where my stuff is.
I can't keep it organized
to save my life.
ERIC SCHMIDT: To each his own.
I'm glad to hear that
your desk isn't just
filling over with drugs.
MEGAN JASPER: No, that's what
the parking lot's for outside.
That's pretty bad too.
My dog almost stepped on
a syringe the other day
and he picked up-- they
have those little drug bags
on the sidewalk all the time.
And he picked one
up in his mouth.
I was like, oh my
God, Pickles, no.
Ready to throw him into rehab.
ERIC SCHMIDT: He's
like a drug runner.
MEGAN JASPER: Totally.
ERIC SCHMIDT: We'll talk about
drugs and some dysfunction
in Seattle in a little bit.
I want to talk about something
that's completely different.
And I want to thank
you for swinging
by on the flippity-flop
to do this today.
If you haven't read
this story back in 1992,
Megan pulled off probably
one of best editorial spoofs
at the time, especially for
a paper like the "New York
Times," where she was asked
to basically kind of explain
grunge and somehow-- you
can fill in the story,
because you did the interview.
But you made up a lexicon,
a language, of grunge-speak
and the "New York
Times" published it.
And it was completely made-up.
It was all bullshit.
MEGAN JASPER: It
was all bullshit.
ERIC SCHMIDT: And
you used words like,
on the flippity-flop, cob
nobbler, which actually is now,
like, a real word.
People use cob nobbler--
MEGAN JASPER: As they should.
ERIC SCHMIDT: Yeah, wax slacks.
So I have two questions.
One, what you were thinking?
And number two, would you
attempt to do that again?
Like, now that Sub-Pop--
it's not small.
Seattle's not small.
You're repping tons of artists.
You were the receptionist.
Now you're the VP.
Would you do it again?
MEGAN JASPER: I would
do it in a heartbeat.
Are you kidding me?
That's what life is all about.
My coworker, Derek, on my way
out today, said, all right.
Do you think I can
get away with this
and promise I won't be fired,
or just tell me right now
and I won't do it.
I'm like, what is it?
I want to make a t-shirt.
It's going to say,
"Trigger" and then an arrow
pointed down to my crotch.
I'm like, of course
you have to do that.
That's like, so rated
G. Are you kidding me?
Do it.
I feel like life is way more
fun when you can laugh at stuff
and when you have
shit to laugh at.
So as long as it's not mean
and it's not hurting people,
I am so all for it.
That happened because
I was so buzzed out
on way too many French presses
that I had in my apartment
at the time.
And when that phone
call came my way,
I just remember
feeling like, yes.
It was, I can either
chat with this person
and come up with some
crazy-ass answers,
or I could go back to work.
So I was like--
ERIC SCHMIDT: If you haven't
read it, you gotta read it.
It's awesome.
And then, who came to the
"New York Times" defense?
Forget the--
MEGAN JASPER: Tom
[? Marron. ?] No,
[? Marron ?] was the
journalist who wrote it.
Tom Frank.
Tom Frank worked at
The Baffler and was
a University of Chicago Ph.D.
student, I think, at the time.
And he ended up
exposing the story.
And I didn't know any of
that stuff was going on.
But I remember him
calling me and saying,
oh, my God, the
"New York Times,"
they feel like such
pussies right now,
and meow, meow, meow.
It's like, awesome.
This sounds fun.
ERIC SCHMIDT: I would
have loved to seen
if we had Twitter and real
time search and everything else
that we have now, just how
differently-- because this
took days to play out.
MEGAN JASPER: I have to say,
my favorite thing about all
of that was that the day it came
out at the "New York Times,"
they did a huge piece on
Seattle, and Seattle culture,
and how to understand the
music, and how people talked.
It's like, blah.
Why would they talk any
differently than anyone else?
But my mom, who got the
"New York Times"-- she lives
in Worcester, Massachusetts.
She calls me up and she
goes, "Jesus Christ,
you're never going
to believe it.
Go out.
Run to the 7-Eleven.
Get the goddamn paper right now.
Go get the Times.
All your bullshit's in it."
And I was like, awesome.
And she was like, "Good girl.
Keep doing the good stuff."
And I'm like, lying?
And so when you get praised
from a parent for telling lies,
it's like, oh, my God, yes.
The world is right.
ERIC SCHMIDT: So most of the
stories that I read third party
and also the
interviews you've done,
the majority, even today
you're so positive, almost
like a duck.
Nothing sticks.
It just washes off your back.
You keep going.
I want to take us back to
a time which is coming up,
calendar-wise.
April 5 marks the anniversary
of Kurt Cobain's death.
And in 1994, they had moved on.
They were on DGC at the time.
But nonetheless,
you had traveled
through many, many
journeys with them.
And can you take us back to
that day, and what did you feel?
What was going on at Sub-Pop?
Kind of know what was
going on in the city,
but can you explain
your reaction to that?
MEGAN JASPER: Yeah.
So for me, at that time
I was working for ADA,
which was Sub-Pop's-- Sub-Pop
is distributed still by ADA
in States.
And I hadn't heard
anything that morning.
And weirdly, every
four or six weeks, I
would have an appointment at
Fred Meyer's, the department
store.
What is it called?
The one-stop shopping store,
whatever the hell it's called?
And I would sell music to them.
And it was always a
little bit more stressful
than my other accounts, because
the buyer was a bit older
than me, had way more
experience than I did.
I was like the little kid
going in there at the time.
And so I always felt like I
had to have my shit together.
And I had to be able
to tell them straight
up why he needed to
buy certain records.
I just had to have everything
together in my head.
And so that morning,
I just remember
driving to their main offices.
And I didn't have the radio on.
I didn't have anything
on, because I was just
trying to kind of make sure
I had my shit together.
And when I walked in there,
the buyer, Don Jensen,
said, what's happening
with Kurt Cobain right now?
And then he told me that a body
had been found in the garage
to the house.
And I remember kind
of feeling shocked.
But I thought, because I
knew that Kurt was in rehab,
that I thought maybe it was my
friend Dylan, who was in Earth.
And I just remember trying to
hold it together and just kind
of get my work done.
The thing that I remember
the most was I walked out
with an order of more
Nirvana records, more any
records than I had ever
walked out with before.
And I felt so
conflicted, because not
knowing if it was
Kurt or not Kurt,
I just was like, oh my God.
This is fucked up.
Like, somebody has died.
And this is what my
job is right now,
is to put in an order for
a whole lot of records
at Fred Meyer.
And so I remember driving home.
And weirdly, there was
an anniversary party
that Sub-Pop was having.
And so everybody from ADA
was flying into Seattle.
And so I had to do airport runs
after that and pick people up.
And I remember people saying--
because here's the thing.
It's like, whenever
anything happens,
we as humans often end up
just projecting our own stuff
onto it.
And so there was a lot
of that, like what's
there to be depressed about?
He had a ton of money.
It's just-- I just remember
hearing a whole lot of stuff
like that and just shutting
up and not saying anything.
But I remember being
terribly concerned,
mostly for Jonathan, who
was in the Sub-Pop offices.
And I knew there was just--
there were news people outside
of those offices.
And it just was bad.
And I remember,
just-- at the time,
you don't know what
anything means.
You have to-- we
gain perspective
by having a beginning
and an end to things.
And then moving
beyond it and having
the ability to process
that whatever lies
in the middle of those things.
And so I just remember not
knowing what any of it meant.
But I remember seeing
a lot of the people
that I know and love
in states of shock.
And it was just a
pretty awful day.
ERIC SCHMIDT: As time moves
on, memorializing folks,
like when David Bowie
passed, we were memorializing
him the next day on the radio.
And so, yeah, as time moves
on, your perspective changes.
Those feelings are still
there, but we can now
reflect on other things.
I was doing some
research, and you
published the original contract
signed in 1989 with Nirvana,
which was very open source
of you guys, so that's great.
You published the
contract online.
And the first advance
was a whopping $600,
to be recouped through
recoupable expenses,
through [INAUDIBLE].
So my question is, how
did Sub-Pop overcome
recouping $600 on Nirvana?
That seems, like,
insurmountable.
MEGAN JASPER: Well,
they're still not recouped.
It's so weird that that first
record was made for $600.
But it was, and it's
a perfect record.
And if there's anything
to take from that,
it is that artists can
do an incredible amount.
I'm not saying that
they always have
to have very little,
what I'm saying
is it's mind-blowing what an
artist can do with very little.
And that record's
an example of that.
And I have to say also, just
going back to Kurt, just
for a second, is that stuff,
I don't know that it will ever
really be reconciled.
But I have to say,
I think there's
something so important about
just remembering that there
are so many people in our world
who are just larger than life.
And at the end of it
all, really, everyone
is just the same, with
struggles and gifts
and joys and challenges.
And Kurt was so no different.
For most of the time
that I knew him,
I always had the feeling that
he would rather kind of sit
back and just watch
and enjoy than be
the center of attention.
And I think no matter how much
money anybody has or how much
success anybody has or not, it's
so important to remember that
we're kind of all in this thing
together and to be mindful
of that and never to think
that you know what anyone
in the world is going
through, because we don't.
ERIC SCHMIDT: I was
thinking that that theme is
kind of pervasive
throughout the artists
that you have repped
over the years, both
the happy ones and
maybe the ones that had
a lot of loser inside of them.
They're all very genuine.
I remember hearing that
album for the first time.
I was like, wow.
Like, I'm angry too.
And this person's angry,
and this is amazing.
MEGAN JASPER: Feels good.
ERIC SCHMIDT: Yeah, feels good.
So I want to switch gears a bit.
I want to talk about the role
of women in the workplace,
specifically in executive roles.
You started out as
the receptionist,
worked and worked through, how
many years now, 24 or 25-ish?
MEGAN JASPER: I started in '89.
ERIC SCHMIDT: But you work in
a highly male dominated field.
And I would say, because
I've been in this space
for a long time, it's not
even so male dominated.
It's also kind of
sleazy at times.
The record business
is a tough business
to be in, meaning there's not a
lot of rules that are enforced.
How did you survive?
And then, what
advice would you give
to women who aspire
to stay the course
and move through,
say, like a rank
and file position to
an executive position?
MEGAN JASPER: I would say
that I survived a lot of it
because I tried
not to give a shit.
And for much of my time,
I didn't give a shit,
meaning that I was way
less mindful of the fact
that I'm a woman.
I also felt like I was just
doing what I love to do
and I felt pretty lost in that.
And I have had the good fortune
to work for a guy, Jonathan,
who's pretty enlightened
and pretty great
and has never made me feel any
less-- I mean, God knows, I
am less in a million
different ways,
but not because I'm a woman.
And so I've never
felt like that.
I also feel like I've
had the good fortune
of helping to shape some of
the culture at the company.
And we have a
pretty equal number
of men and women in the company.
And if anyone showed
signs of being an asshole
to anyone because of who they
are or what they look like
or what their deal
is, there's just
no room for that in our office.
So I was maybe
sheltered from it a bit.
And I would say that
the biggest challenge
I think that women
have-- because women
are obviously every
bit as capable as men.
But the biggest challenge I
think is women having families.
Because to be able
to work in a place
where you can step
away and have a baby
and then be able to take
care of that baby in a way
that a mom needs to, whatever
that means for any mom,
it's different than a guy.
I think there are
wonderful things
that men bring to a child and
that women bring to a child.
But women have such
a greater challenge
of continuing with their
careers when they have families.
And I know a lot
of women in music
and in other jobs who
have had to switch gears
in order to provide
for their kids.
So I would say if
you are a woman
and you're in that
position, just do everything
in your power to stick
with it if that's really
what you love to do.
And also, I think
you can't feel badly
for prioritizing your kid
over your friggin' job,
because you kind of-- that's
what I would do if I had kids.
Fuck, I have two dogs.
And I'm sure there
are people in my life
who have been afraid that I
might start breastfeeding them,
because I have a completely
dysfunctional relationship
with them.
And if I could have kids,
I'd probably be a puppy mill,
meaning if they came out
looking like furry puppies,
I'd be like, why not have more?
Because I love a dog.
But I think it's just
challenging for women.
And I feel like it's all
of our responsibilities
to make sure that we are mindful
and sensitive to especially
women in the workplace
and especially women who
are having families.
Because that's ultimately
what it's all about.
I mean, we have to
die off for a few
more generations
in order for things
to be a whole lot better.
So we kind of need
some kids in the world.
ERIC SCHMIDT: I love the
family reinforcement again.
I want to go home and
give my little guy
a hug after listening to that.
There's nothing in
my question flow
that talks about how you jump
from breastfeeding puppies
to the next question.
So I want to talk about Seattle.
The analogy I was
using is Sub-Pop
was the womb, if
you will, of kind
of birthing the original four
and then kind of nurturing
the city in terms of
growing music culture.
And this place is completely
different in many ways
from the late '80s
and early '90s.
It's one of the
fastest-growing cities.
We're competing back and
forth between Austin, which
we are way cooler than Austin.
No offense to Austin, but I
was there a couple weeks ago
and Seattle's way cooler.
MEGAN JASPER: I agree.
ERIC SCHMIDT: Good.
But there's a ton of change
happening in the city.
People are honking their horns.
They're driving too fast.
People aren't saying
"no worries" anymore.
It's like, who are these people?
It's like this confluence of
people that aren't Seattleites.
And then you have impacts
of things like restrictions
on live music venues.
Folks like here
in Fremont, Nectar
is under a lot of
pressure because there's
too much tolerance for noise
because we want higher density
housing, a decline in
artistry because it's just
too damn expensive.
It's really
expensive, especially
where your offices are up
on Capital Hill, et cetera.
And then you also have
the cultural aspects
of how people consume music,
snacking one at a time,
spending $0.99, listening to a
stream that they don't pay for.
How has this impacted
Sub-Pop in terms
of how it feels about
Seattle, and where do you
think it's headed?
MEGAN JASPER: It's such
the question right now.
ERIC SCHMIDT: I realize that
was three questions in one.
MEGAN JASPER: That's OK.
So as far as-- OK,
it's so funny because I
was thinking about this
exact thing this morning.
Because I'm one of
the commissioners
on the city's-- Tom Mara is too.
Seattle has 21
music commissioners
who do outreach programs
and talk to people
and find out what the challenges
are and try ultimately
to put together work
plans that make music
a greater experience
for people in the city.
And when you have
exactly those challenges,
the biggest one being
Seattle is very expensive
to live in-- so how
can an artist who's
struggling to have a
career live here and not
go to Portland or LA, which is
happening constantly right now?
I don't know exactly what the
solution will end up being.
But I do know that
it's something
that we're having-- at
least everyone's having it--
but we're having
that conversation
and trying to pull in
our local politicians
to help find answers
to those things.
And I spoke to the folks
at Nectar just last week
about what they're
going through.
And it is interesting, because
that's not a super high density
neighborhood.
But the complaints are actually
coming from Queen Anne.
And what it sounded
like to me is
that that sound is
traveling in such a way,
probably with the wind
at times, where it's
hitting a small number
of people on Queen Anne,
where they're hearing,
like, sentences
during someone's sound check,
even, which is bizarre.
But I don't know
what the solution is.
But what I do know
is that I think
the city is a pretty great
city, with some big challenges,
for sure, that need
to be figured out.
I hate driving to
work every day.
Do you drive in from
West Seattle every day?
It sucks.
And you have to figure out how
to make the commute bearable.
It's tough.
But the city is a great city.
And I believe that there are
solutions to every problem
so long as you want
to find the solutions.
And it's our job
for sure at Sub-Pop
and for sure at other music
organizations in the city
to help find the answers
to those questions.
And I don't know what
they are right now.
But I will tell you that
I feel really determined
to help figure that out.
And it needs to get figured out.
ERIC SCHMIDT: One of the things
that I've personally been doing
and my friends have been doing
is reinforcing to our friends
and as we meet new people
is to go and see live music.
And also buy the music.
So going out and
seeing and supporting.
People are doing that less.
And as that dies off, then
the venues start to die off.
And I was thinking about back
in the late '80s and early '90s,
that was one of the amazing
things about Seattle.
You could roll in and see
Nirvana or Soundgarden,
Tad, et cetera, live onstage.
And yeah, it was really loud.
And probably people in
Queen Anne were pissed off.
But that's what
created the culture
and pulled through the cutlture.
So go see live music
and buy the records.
You started a new
label concept in 2007
called Hardly Arts
where you were
splitting profit versus
taking points on royalties.
Some of my favorite
artists-- Seapony,
Taco Cat, Chastity Belt--
how is this business doing?
MEGAN JASPER: It's doing
really, really well.
So we spent many years kind
of figuring it out and trying
to understand how it
would work as a company.
It's nine years old now
and it's doing super well.
And we were talking
about one of the bands
earlier at lunch,
which is Gazebos.
They're one of my
favorites right now.
But the thing that's
interesting that's happening
at Hardly Art-- and it was
not a conscious thing--
but there are so
many female artists.
It kind of goes back
to the other stuff
we were talking about.
Chastity Belt, La Luz,
Gazebos, Taco Cat, and more--
and there's really
good stuff coming out
that I don't know that
I can talk about yet.
But it's super exciting.
And it's very
female-driven right now.
And the women who
are in those bands
are extraordinary human beings.
And they're making great music.
So I have to say it makes
me crazy happy right now.
The company's doing well.
ERIC SCHMIDT: Maybe there's
something more attractive
or logical for a
female to say, I'd
rather have equitable
distribution
versus cutting some more
aggressive point deals.
I would only speculate.
I have a bunch of
other questions,
but I want to open
it up to the audience
so that you can ask
questions, if you have them.
AUDIENCE: How's it going?
Actually, spent a little time
when I was little in Wooster.
How do you say it?
MEGAN JASPER: I think you're
supposed to say Wuster,
but we all say Woosta.
AUDIENCE: I was, like, three.
My dad called it Ustern.
And so I when I looked for
it later in life, I was like,
U-S-T-E-R-N. This
place doesn't exist.
So my question
is, I write songs.
But I have a day job
and I have a family.
So I'm not going to tour for the
next 10 years and hit the road.
So years ago, I used
Taxi for placing a song
in the little spot
on a TV thing.
Is that still viable?
Should I just focus
on YouTube videos?
What's the thing that someone
who's not trying to be
in a band and tour , but
rather just write songs?
What's a good avenue
for that these days?
MEGAN JASPER: That's an
interesting question.
I think that probably,
it's a matter
of finding good publishing.
Because if you can write music
and send it to some publishing
companies, a really
great publishing company
will be able to work
with you and then
maybe even engage another artist
in performing those songs.
And I think if you can find
a setup like that, that
seems like the thing to do.
But I would also say
that if that's not
possible or achievable right
now for whatever reason,
I would just keep posting
shit and making it available.
And I don't mean "shit."
But what I mean is, I think when
you put your stuff out there,
people will access it.
And that's the most
important thing
is just getting it up and out.
AUDIENCE: I wanted
to get your take
on what the role
of record labels
might be a generation
or two from now.
So my first real introduction
to them was from a movie.
It was Ray Charles biopic.
And I watched the movie
and it seemed so beautiful.
And it took me back to a
time that may or may not
have existed in reality, but it
made for a beautiful impression
of what the equation between
an artist and a record label
might be like.
And it was a really
close, tight bond.
I don't know how
things are today
or how things might
be in the future,
but could you add
some context to that?
MEGAN JASPER: Yes.
I love that question, because I
think what you were connecting
with there, that that bond
and the understanding of who
someone is as far
as their art goes
is, if you can put that into
a mission statement, that's
what every label's mission
statement should be.
Because what that is, is
understanding who an artist is
and understanding how
to get their music out
into the world in a way that
works for them and connects
people with that
music-- connects
with people who will
be moved by that music.
So ultimately, that is what a
record label will always be,
because you're not a label
without doing the A&R.
You're not a label without
finding the artists.
It's probably the
most important thing.
Because then you have
something to market.
You have something to sell.
You have something to stream.
However it is that
people consume music,
you don't do anything
without the music.
So all of that other stuff
is the stuff that changes.
And how you sell music, how you
listen to music, how you first
hear a song, that stuff
is always going to change.
But finding the artist that you
can work with and work really
well with, that is what
a label should always be.
And then how it goes out into
the world-- that can evolve.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Are there any misconceptions
about the music industry,
and what might some of
the biggest ones be?
MEGAN JASPER: That show
"Vinyl" is probably
really good at spotlighting it.
So are there are a lot of drugs?
Sometimes.
Is everyone breaking
rules and doing
shit they shouldn't be doing?
Sometimes.
But not to that degree.
I would say the
biggest misconception
is that it's just fun, like rock
and roll times all the time.
And that's not really the case.
So for example, if I know I'm
going to have a long day and I
have meetings with artists and
their managers most of the day
and I really care about how
those meetings are going to go,
the last thing I'm going to do
is go out drinking until 2:00
in the morning the night
before, because I can't.
I mean, I have to pull
it together and do right
by the company I work
for and the artist.
So it's not like-- it's just
not Partyville constantly.
I mean, it would be nice
if there was a little more
Partyville sometimes.
But I feel like I beat
myself up over that stuff.
Like, I kind of
want to be on and I
want to bring my best
to whatever it is.
And my coworkers
feel the same way.
I mean, maybe they're
a little bit--
I hope they're a little bit
looser than I am about it.
But I think that's the
biggest misconception.
And maybe even going back
to the whole female thing,
I think the role
of the woman who
was the A&R person in
that first episode,
it was so bogus to me, because
I guess in our world-- and not
just Sub-Pop, but
like-minded labels-- there
are a lot of women in
positions of power.
And they're not
just sandwich girls
or-- it's a funny portrayal.
But I'd say those
are the biggest ones.
It's not party
time all the time.
It's usually like, fucking
suck it up and work well time,
and then maybe you can have
a glass of wine afterwards.
AUDIENCE: I was
excited to hear you
talk about the singles
club, because I
remember that I was a kid.
And just this idea
that, like, I'm
committing to buy everything
that Sub-Pop puts out
for the year before-- like,
silencing-- before I've even
heard it.
And you talked about what
the role of labels are
and that it's about discovery
and developing artists.
And as you were
talking about it,
I was kind of thinking back,
that's exactly what the singles
club kind of was.
It was like that
and record stores
was where I would
go to find stuff.
And I think about the shift
that's happened since then.
Like lots of record stores
have closed and everything.
And social is now a big part
of how people find things.
And I just was curious to hear
your thoughts on how Sub-Pop
has weathered that
shift, I guess,
where it's like, how are
people finding things?
All the work you guys are
doing to develop artists--
how is that being
understood by people?
MEGAN JASPER: Well,
I think we are
lucky that we've been a company
for as long as we have been,
because like you said, you
would buy a record without even
knowing what the
music sounded like.
I think at some point, Matador
Records, Merge Records,
whatever it is, it
becomes an endorsement.
And so I think we are lucky
in that a lot of people
will come to our website and
wonder what we're putting out
or what's next.
And I think that's
something that we're
able to offer an
artist that's unique,
because we've been
around long enough.
We still try in all the same
ways to get the bands out
there is as much as we're able.
But ultimately, I think
what it comes down
to is being able to serve as
an endorsement in the same way
that Pitchfork does.
You'll go to Pitchfork
and wonder what is best
new music or best new track.
And I think labels serve
that same purpose, sort of,
in acting as a filter.
Like, there's so
much stuff out there,
but here's a means
to filter that stuff.
And then maybe I
can hear something
that I wouldn't have
heard otherwise.
FEMALE SPEAKER:
Thank you, Megan.
We're out of time, but thank you
so much for coming and speaking
with us.
MEGAN JASPER: Thank you for
tolerating me and having me.
[APPLAUSE]